you're all welcome to join us for this
favorite district council planning
committee meeting on the 26th of august
first of all may i remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements
please ensure that the microphones and
cameras
are turned off when not in use that you
do not interrupt
other speakers if you wish to speak
points of order declare and interest or
requested in german
please use the hands up function on the
task
button and after you've spoken please
remember to
turn it off because you have to turn it
off
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open other than scope chats
and that if you are contacted by a third
party during
an application you should bring this to
the legal advisors attention
that if you're attempting attending the
meeting
sorry that if you are attending the
meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt you
you may be asked to leave
if members do lose connection to the
meeting
that they must contact the member
supports officers
as soon as possible i would like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet
and will be capable of repeat viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where they are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council
and to the possible use of these sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd now like to introduce you to the
officers
that we have today present mark russell
area planner
manager jasmine weinard
case officer indy press planning lawyer
and claire
philpott governance officer i'd now like
to move to the agenda
i'm gonna ask for uh apologies
and absence um can we
have the um roll call for members please
claire thank you chair thank you when i
call your name if you could just
indicate your presence for me please
councillor sue ayers present counselor
melanie barrett
present councillor peter beer present
councillor dave busby president
councillor john hinton president
councillor lee jameson
present councillor mary mclaren
president
councillor adrian osborne present
councillor alison owen present
council stephen plum president and we
have apologies from councillor lee
parker
yeah thank you i believe we still
haven't
got councillor jane gould on the line
okay we'll carry on until we get to that
now
stop again we'll find out
right is there any uh decorations by
members
i'll take that as none there's no hands
up
thank you there's none to declare
item three to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 15th of july
these are to follow
and you don't know yet when they're
going to be ready
for being signed
so we'll move on to item four
which is to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 29th of july
these also are to follow
when approved the minutes will be signed
at the next a practical
opportunity chair apologies i believe
those minutes were in the table papers
were they not
uh have you seen mine
yes i think i could see the moves over
it says here to follow right um
so we have the minutes for the 29th of
july
and so i need to ask if there's any
points of accuracy
needs to be clarified members
yeah no can i have a proposal then
please
well sorry chair yeah to be honest if
they were in the
table papers i haven't read those yet
i think they only turn up and you saw
them this morning i assumed that table
papers were the same as we've got here
there was no mention of being anything
extra being added into them
well we can delay them until the next
meeting so it gives you time then to
read them because
yes they did come through rather late
well or if we could do them at the end
of the meeting and just have a five
minute break while we have a chance to
read them
uh yes i suppose that's possible i think
members are happy with that
yes no one's saying no so i'll take take
that as yes so we'll come back to that
at the end of the meeting okay
thank you so we'll move on to item
number five to receive notification of
any petitions
um claire do we have any no chair we do
not
thank you then we'll move to item six
site inspections i have to go through
this procedure
officers are there any site inspection
requests
um mark
you're muted yeah none that way of chair
and still obviously the advice is not
not to do them
thank you members are there any site
inspection requests
no thank you so we note all that
we'll move on then we've got to item
seven
now this is where we need to know about
the ward member but i think the ward
member can join us at any point during
this
because she's she doesn't have any
voting rights
so um claire uh harriet wasn't it
have you managed to contact her
uh yesterday i did contact her but there
was no response to her mobile phone
so um i'm afraid we haven't got her
counselor gold here at the moment
no okay well we'll carry on if she
arrives perhaps
you would interrupt us and just tell us
she's present um but members
she doesn't have to be present uh for
this but it's always useful as she is
right um then i'll move invite the case
officer
jane weiner to introduce the application
which is
on your paperwork before you and if
you've got the papers in front of you
it's on page 11. okay jasmine
thank you chair and good morning members
um i'm just
going to get the powerpoint up so just
bear with me one second
can everyone say that they were just
saying a picture of you
ah yes that's come out yeah yep okay
so um i'll be presenting dc200701 to you
today
and the site is klondike field west of
bourne hill in worsted
um and it's a reserved matters
application for the scale layout
appearance and landscaping for the
erection of 75 dwellings
following outline permission dc eighteen
zero zero seven zero six um hopefully
we've seen from the table
papers as well there have been some
slight changes um specifically regarding
suffolk county council floods whose
responses
from a holding objection has now changed
and as part of this condition 33 is no
longer part of the description
so the site is shown outlined in red
it's fully within the parish of worsted
and
the a137 runs along the north western
boundary
um so you'll see that there's the
woodland south
um which i'll discuss um
in a little while under the plan in
history uh there are a row of houses
along bourne hill
um and the site would be accessed via
bourne terrace which is
uh west of bourne hill as shown sort of
by the star there
um there are there's also um
puddle duck kinder care um which is a
day nursery which is located to the
south
west corner of um the proposed dwellings
and the site
which you can see there as well
then you've got the the site location
plan shown
um just it shows the the site outlined
in red
and you've got the planning history so
um in december
2018 members were presented with a
hybrid application
um so it formed it had two parts
so there was an outline application for
the erection of 75 dwellings
and which included access to be
considered
and then a full application which is for
the change of use
from the private woodland to a suitable
alternative natural green space
community woodland um so it's really the
the northern
um undeveloped field that we're looking
at today
um so the principle has been established
and the access has been approved all
other matters
are being discussed today um there was
an mma granted
earlier this year which slightly altered
some technical details of the access but
nothing
material to discuss there and as i say
that's already been granted
um and the section 106 um
section 106 was also signed as part of
the um outline
and full application there which secured
rams contributions um affordable housing
mix and management of the community
woodland
so the key issues are essentially the
reserve matters so appearance
scale layout and the landscaping
and and there are several conditions are
included as part of the um
development description which are they
they could be dealt with
under um a discharge conditions
application
but these have quite a bit of overlap
with the reserve matters
um so they have been included in the
description for completeness
and the details of which are therefore
included in this application as well
um conditions four six and seven of the
outline
are also conditions which the reserve
matters has to
accord with so they relate to general
conformity with
a layout plan provided outline
a no build zone which again was provided
on a plan
outline and a cross-section of the
layout which
i'll come to in a little while as well
and these will all be presented to you
on my latest slides
so this is the first constraints map so
you've got uh
three listed buildings um to the east of
the site so you've got
a public house to the north which is um
the ostrich inn public house and then
you've got
to the south um south east you've got um
numbers one and two born hall
um both of which are great too listed um
you've also got a public right way
running north and west
of the site as well
do you have a house can you just hover
that over those areas you're talking
about
see my mouse at all okay no oh brilliant
okay because
last time you couldn't see it brilliant
so you've got the
um grey two listed buildings here and
here
and then you've got the the public right
of way sort of running
um north west of the site along here
and we've got the second um constraints
map
um which i realize that there's quite a
lot on here
primarily um the sort of thing to note
is that there's a part of the site to
the north
is it is within flood zone two and so
that's just
here it's a very small slither to the
north
and you've then got some several
constraints sort of around the site but
the one
that constrains partially constrained to
site is this flood zone here
right
um so i've got some photos for you as
well so the top two
are taken along born hill
um so you can see that the access is
here
and this access runs um
just along here towards the site
and that's bourne terrace this would be
upgraded as part of the outline
application and as i say access has
already been approved
and then you've got the the dwellings
you can see are set at a
slightly higher level than actually born
um hill itself
and the land sort of levels um
just to the west of um these dwellings
to the rear
as well um
the bottom two um photos here
show the rear elevations of the
dwellings um along bourne hill
so again you can see that there's a sort
of mixture of different fencing
um some natural screening from
um the trees and also
um you've got some slightly more exposed
um dwellings as well there are also a
mixture of bungalows
chalet bungalows and two story dwellings
but again i'll explain that a little bit
more detail later on
um in terms of where i was standing to
take these photos
um i was standing far closer um
to the the dwellings the existing
dwellings than the proposed dwellings
would be so that's
that's probably something just to bear
in mind
um so these are again photos these are
actually of the site now so i was
standing along this sort of
informal path here when taking the
photos of the rear elevations of the
existing dwellings which are just
located
to the east and this again
you can see that the site slightly falls
um
towards the west and the north there um
but it's slightly more even towards the
east
again this bit is the access going down
and would sort of come in to the site as
well
and then this is the western um well
south western boundary and this would be
um puddle duck
kinder care which is the day nursery so
that's the existing boundary there
um so the site layout that was on the
outline
um there are there are two that i'll
show you today
these two were the ones that were
included under conditions
on the outline so there's a no build
area
um to the north west side of the site
um and as part of condition six
this had to um any reserve matters that
come
forward had to make sure that there
wasn't any building within this area
similar sort of principle as well with
this site layout plan so again this was
on the outline
so not including the reserve matters but
on the outline and condition four
stated that this uh that any reserve
matters that come forward
also have to be in general conformity
with
this layout as well
so this is the site layout that's been
proposed
um there are 22 dwellings per hectare
and
i've shown you some separation distances
just to the side here
so this is sort of the maximum
separation distance and the minimum
um this is between the
nearest elevation to the boundary and
then also the nearest elevation to the
rear elevation
of the existing dwellings as well so you
can get an idea of the separation
distances there
um
okay so you've then got the site um
layout plans
side by side so this is firstly to do
with condition six
so i'm sure you can agree that there is
this no build area which is secured via
condition on the outline
and that has been adhered to um and the
reserve matters is in accordance with
that
the same is then shown for general
conformity with the layout
on this uh morning account is henrik
holloway from baby suffolk community
services
um i'm just checking
so the condition for um
is obviously for the the general
conformity with the layout and again
and you can see on the reserve matters
that it is in general conformity with
this layout
so the housing mix um
is so that the affordable housing mix
has been secured via the section 106
um and the open market mix
again um there was nothing on the
outline or in the section 106 to
indicate
what this mix should be and so this is
what's been proposed
um in terms of i'll again i'll discuss
this in
some of my latest slides to do with the
extent of bungalows
um that was indicated outline and we
don't currently have a policy
um for the extent that bungalows should
be provided
on site and the nearest thing we have to
it is our emerging joint local plan
policy lp06
um which indicates you know it's a
direction of travel but it indicates
that
um sites should accommodate three
percent bungalows
um and in to this end the
reserve matters does provide that three
percent
but that's something for members to sort
of bear in mind
um so this is the indicative story
heights that were shown to you
um outline so there are 16
um bungalows here specifically along
um the western boundary and the eastern
boundary
and the the rest were two-story with
some one and a half story
um garages as well
so this is the story heights that have
been proposed under the reserve matters
application
so you've got the three bungalows here
and here
you've then got a partially three-story
apartment block
and the rest of the dwellings are two
stories with
single-story garages
um so what i've shown here um is the
neighboring dwelling heights
and so you've got a mixture as i've said
earlier of bungalows chalet bungalows
and two-story dwellings
um as i indicated earlier there is
a significant separation distance both
um
the minimum which is sort of to the
north here um
which only gets larger as you go to the
south
um in terms of the
to this end there would be no
detrimental impact on
overlooking or loss of privacy to the
dwellings here so
in terms of the lack of bungalows along
the eastern boundary
um officers don't believe that there is
any sort of
detrimental impact on um residential
immunity of neighbouring dwellings that
are that exist along bourne hill
um so this is the affordable housing
plan
um which shows the affordable rent units
in blue and the shared ownership in red
um both
so there are 26 affordable dwellings
as per the section 106. um
they are not pepper potted however they
would be built in the second phase um
of the development after the
construction of the spine road
um therefore there is public benefit
through the early delivery
of these
and so this is just to i'll go through
the affordable dwellings
um and then i'll also go through the
open market dwellings on the following
slides just to
sort of show you that they are
completely tenure blind
um so these are the the two story
dwellings so you've got two bedrooms and
three bedrooms
then you've got the bungalows so the
two-bedroom they're both two-bedroom but
one is for
three people the other is four people
and you've got the affordable apartments
and so again these are a mixture of one
and two bedrooms
and then the open market so these are
the
larger of the two-story dwelling so
these are both four bedrooms
then you've got the three bedrooms
semi-detached there um
two bedrooms which again you should note
that these
are very very similar to the affordable
housing and they are
completely tenure blind
and then we've got the materials here
so there's a mixture of materials and
again
in terms of ensuring the affordables
over here attenua blind you can see that
they have very similar materials to
the rest and it's all sort of um
interspersed with the the same materials
and so there's three different bricks
um between red and cream bricks which
are all
um traditional to suffolk and you've
also got
the um two different roof tiles they are
both
um concrete but they are both to imitate
slate and plane tiles which again are um
traditional suffolk um materials and
you've got some
weatherboarding as well sort of dotted
around shown by the pink dots
and which again breaks down the street
scenes which i'll show you
now so they are
very visually attractive street scenes
um
the different architectural features um
throughout there's not
any sort of uniform appearance and again
you can see that there's no
deterioration as you come off of the
spine road
further into the estates and they all
sort of retain that same sense of place
so this is the parking layout and there
are 185 spaces in total
including 19 visitor spaces which are
shown
um in the orange brown color so they're
sort of along here and here
um you've got the the green shows the on
plot parking provision and there is
further provision
included in the garages as well
cycle storage is either provided in the
garage or in
sheds in gardens and they're shown by
the blue
dots here um there are some
small matters that are being discussed
and clarified with suffolk county
council highways at the minute and these
relate
primarily to conditions 16 and 18
of the outline um it's important to note
that highways don't raise any objection
to the reserve matters
application though so that's just
something to bear in mind
and so we've got the boundary treatments
here so there's a mixture of brick walls
and clothes boarded fencing large lap
fencing
um so along the western boundary
you've got um a close boarded fences one
they're all 1.8 meters
um and again you've got a 1.8 close
1.8 meter close boarded fence um along
the eastern boundary
as well um and combined with the
landscaping which i'll show you on the
next slide
um there is it's considered that there
is significant and sufficient screening
along both of these um sensitive
boundaries and
also to the western um the north western
boundary
with the a137 there's an existing post
and rail fence
and under condition 18 which again is
still being discussed with suffolk
county council highways
um they're ensuring that there's
clarification
and sufficient measures that
are in place to ensure that no one
enters the a137
um so that's again quite important to
note
um so this is the landscaping master
plan that's been provided
and some of the specific details are
being considered and amended
under the conditions um place services
landscaping
raise an objection to this overall
strategy strategy though
um so in terms of there
there will be some very very slight um
amendments and discussions to be had
there but i think the
majority of this landscaping scheme
um has now been um agreed with them
and they're they're happy with it and
again you can see that there's some
native hedgerow along the western
boundary
and trees along the eastern boundary
which again
ensures that the existing business and
dwellings over here to the west
and the existing dwellings over to the
east are sufficiently separated and
screened as well
ensuring again there is no overlooking
or loss of privacy
um to any residential amenity there
um it's also as you can see heavily
landscaped there's a lot of public open
space
and a lot of native hedgerows native
trees and there's also
two sort of pathways um outside of
the main estate road so you've got a
moan path that comes
along sort of the north western boundary
here
and again a gravel pathway going along
the eastern boundary
which link to go towards um the north in
towards ipswich
and other natural green infrastructure
elsewhere as well
um so
the recommendation is that the reserve
matters application is granted
alongside the conditions that have been
noted
in the description say for conditions 16
and 18
details which are being finalized
currently
thank you thank you very much um
right i'll see whether any members got
any
points of clarification that they'd like
to put to i've just got one
can you just confirm that um when the
outline was put forward
the indicative plans shoe 16 bungalows i
think you said
and we're now down to three is that
correct yes that is correct
yeah members have you got any points of
clarification you you wish to have from
the
officers uh yes i've got councillor
hinton followed by councillor ayers
and then councillor osborne
yes a couple of points on page
11 of the of the papers
it talks about description of
development application for approval of
reserve matters following outline
approval
dc 18 stroke 00706
outline planning application access to
be considered
uh we then look at page 15 where there
appear to be one two
three four five six seven
matters regarding conditions
including access i assume because he
doesn't actually mention the access in
there
which had been approved under delegated
authority so why is this coming back to
us
if all the decisions have already been
made
um can you help out chesman or
mark so in terms of
so the access was considered under the
outline application
um under this reserve matters
application the access
isn't being considered um i've purely
just sort of gone through it so you know
that that has already been approved and
that's where the access is
in terms of there was an nma granted um
which dealt with some very very small
technical details that had changed
under this application there is no um
there's no consideration of any changes
to the access
the only thing that we're looking at um
from a highways perspective is is really
the the parking
um and the parking layout and that's
really
it um does that clarify
or have you got not i'm not sure that
actually answers
john's question but john can you
not really because um
when was the access actually approved
and by who
so the access would have been granted in
december 2018
under the outline application because it
was a matter of concentration at that
point
yes by members right yep
doesn't seem to show that which is a bit
confusing um
because the the reason behind my
questions on this is because when we
look
at further on in the papers when i can
find it again because unfortunately we
get rather a lot of people with these
things
um i will find it because i put a formal
question in
yeah on page six it says delegation to
the chief act
acting chief planning officer delegated
powers under minute number 48
a of the council dated the 19th of
october 2014.
well i would susp includes power to
determine the conditions to be imposed
upon and grant
any grant of paying permission etc etc
etc well
the problem with that of course is that
2004
most councillors on this committee
weren't even members of the council
since then we've had three local plans
uh three local
uh chief executives and i think four uh
heads of planning
isn't it about time that uh councillors
were asked to look at these delegated
powers and decide just what they want to
give
because at the moment i don't know what
the delegated powers are that the
officers have got are
uh and consequently we have no control
over what is happening on this planning
process
and yet we as a committee are the
quasi-legal
um enforcement part of the council's
planning policy
i think that's the second part to your
question but that's very fair point
um mark uh can you help on here because
i think
certainly the second part of john's
comments
may something that we need to take away
and look at
um but uh so there's like two parts
there but i'm still concerned that
the answer that he wanted on the first
part
hasn't been completely satisfied i i
i mean let me unpick this obviously
counseling has
made some uh comments about the scheme
of delegation obviously that's
that's out with our consideration today
and that's one to take away
um the the hard facts are the access was
approved by committee
in december 2018. i'm just looking at
the resolution here to check that i'm
not going to mislead you on this
um so the recommendation was
that permission be granted um
subject on the outline that the
chief planning officer be authorized to
grant outline planning commissions
subject to conditions including and then
there was a set of conditions
so that that was a resolution in
december 2018
um following committee thank you
i think the second part we need where is
that in the papers
mr chairman sorry in the actual papers
uh i don't know whether the minutes for
the last meeting
uh quoted anywhere in this report
ken jasmine or that would have been that
would have been a 2018
minute um but where does it say in the
planning for history for instance
just what the grant of planning
permission actually
um i think at the top of the report
unless i've
got this wrong it does say
uh application for approval of reserve
matters following outline approval
dc stroke 18 007.06
yeah application is that the one you
refer to it says
hybrid application outline planning
application brackets access to be
considered erection of 75 dwellings
etcetera
uh decision granted 7th of the 8th 2019
which was obviously the
106 after committee in december so i
mean i take the point that some more
details would have been useful for for
the councillor but it does
it does say there what was granted back
in 2018-19
right and i think the second part uh
council hinton
will take away and i will ask officers
to look at that point
and i think i'll also pass it on to the
cabinet member for planning and
counselor clive arthur to see if we can
um revisit this
okay uh any other oh yes i've got her
next
counselor airs you very much chair
um and thank you for that presentation
jasmine i found it really
quite good um can i just ask on slide 32
about the gravel um pathway having
taught special needs for years and
pushed an awful lot of wheelchairs
um maybe gravel is not always so um
you know could it not be something else
just a point
that's very good point jasmine uh yeah
so
um i suppose in terms of the the
landscaping scheme that's something that
our
play services landscaping team would be
looking into
um it might be something um to bring to
the developers attention
um i suppose that's something that we
can
possibly take away um i think um sorry
to interrupt but i think um
cancel airs perhaps um the applicant i
think is present
uh you could put that question to them
okay thank you chair thank you thank you
uh councillor osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman uh the the
question really is about the um
apartment block the three-story plot
apartment block
i just wanted to know jasmine could uh
determine what height the
uh build is going to be on is that the
lowest point of the site or
is that quite a high point of the site
please
um it's sort of towards so it'd be a
lower point of sight if i just get up
some of the street scenes i believe they
were
on there so that's the apartment block
there
if that sort of helps um as you can see
it's slightly
a lower level um than the neighboring
dwellings so these would be two story
and that's obviously the three story
um and there isn't a huge difference um
in the height there
all right okay thank you thank you right
now
points for clarification
right uh excuse me chairman yes could i
just
sorry who's that it's melanie barrett oh
right sorry oh yes i'd say you're in a
different place your hands come up on my
screen though
yeah counselor barrett yes thank you
jasmine could you just show us the slide
again where it shows the location of the
garages
um some parking layout
it might be yes so
can you just confirm is the is there
some areas
at the ends of those those sort of
turnings
um where there's um just a uh a garage
area that's
um not adjacent to the house but in a
separate area
um so on the
eastern side i was just looking at that
area where there's a
turning hammerhead
here yeah hammerhead that's the
hammerhead yeah
or on the the eastern side um just
but that might be the same also um
are they parking blocks or are they
garages
um so the the green shows these are
parking
um on plot parking bays so the yellow
is where the garages are right
there's more park and bays than there is
garage parking
uh yes yep yeah okay thank you
yeah okay uh
any other people members with
complaints of clarification no thank you
then we'll move on we have public
speakers now uh we have the represent
from the parish council that's robin
coates
you say i have three minutes in which to
address the committee
when you're ready um
claire you'll do the timing please yes
chair i will too
thank you good morning well thank you
for the opportunity to speak to you
today
on behalf of the residents of worsted
worsted parish council and residents
believe the revised site
site design submitted as part of the
reserve matters
does not comply with condition four of
the outline planning permission
granted by this committee in august 2019
when pidgin worst designed the original
site plan they made much of the fact
that the new houses to be built behind
the existing homes on bourne's hill
would be stored close to minimizing
impact on residents this aspect was
included in the design layout
put forward as part of the outline
planning permission and was reflected in
the original development having 17
bungalows
as part of the 75 homes i have rechecked
that i still believe it's 17 and not 16.
worsted parish council and the residents
believe that the importance of this
feature was recognized by the planning
officer
and this committee so included in
condition 4 of the outline approval
which states
that any subsequent reserve matter
applications shall be in general
conformity with the layout
set out on the plan titled overall
sketch layout 01.
however the reserve matters submission
before you today from beltway
has reduced the number of bungalows in
the development from 17
down to three and consequently the new
houses to be constructed behind the
existing bourne hill homes
will be two-story rather than
single-story bungalows
when beltway were asked why this aspect
has changed the parish councils were
advised that belway
do not build bungalows although rather
confusingly they are prepared to build
the three bungalows on this site
just not the full complement of 17 as
per the original design
worsted parish council and residents
believe this is a material change
and that the reserve matters are no
longer in general conformity with the
original submission
and as such it is non-compliant with
both the letter
and the spirit of the conditions of the
original outline permission
we therefore requested the planning
committee compel beltway
to comply with the outline condition and
reinstate the bungalows on the plots to
the rear of the existing homes on bourne
hill
thank you very much for your time thank
you very much for that
um right uh i'll see whether there's
any questions to you um i've got one
to start um you're saying 17 and not 16.
okay that's fair comment um so when you
saw the outline
uh planning application and bearing in
mind it was indicative
um you were of the impression there was
16 possibly 17 bungalows is that correct
um well i've recounted them on the
drawing whilst you were talking earlier
whilst you were going through the
presentation
and the documentation i have is
definitely 17. i also believe in the
papers that were submitted to your
committee
um that in one section the planning
officer's comments were that the change
was from 17 to
3. so i i do believe that's correct and
this has been an amendment i'm unaware
of
no and you did also state august 2019
uh something that would come back to us
in august 2019.
uh i took the date off um uh forgive me
i can't remember isabelle's family name
but um the
the senior planning officer approval uh
which was dated i thought august 2019.
right i'll get i'll get our officers to
check that mark perhaps you can look
into that that he
there was reference from this uh parish
council that
we'd approved something in august 2019
or something was dated 2019.
i need you to clarify that
um i understand that might be the
section 106 um
date um i think jaz actually jasmine may
be able to answer that
jasmine can you come come in there yeah
so um i believe that the committee
um approved it in december 2018. that's
correct
the section 106 date and the date that
the permission was actually
um granted would have been in august
2019
oh right that's right that's fine we're
clear now we're talking
the same thing right members uh no
questions to the paris council yes
councillor busby
okay i've got the uh layout that was
approved the outline layout that was
approved and there's actually 16
bungalows i think this
uh 13 open market and
three um affordable housing
so that's just to clarify that pointer
and um
i just say welcome to robin again it's
obviously feels like it's on the planet
committee bearing in mind we've done
nothing but worsted for the last three
months
thank you very much councillor busby any
other comments members
sorry any other questions to um mr
coates
no thank you very much we'll move on
thank you
right we don't have an objector or
supporter so now i asked the agent to
speak
sarah conwell you have three minutes in
which to address the
committee when you're ready thank you
good morning members and thank you for
allowing me to speak i am the planner
for bellway homes in respect to the
reserve matters application for klondike
field
i'd like to thank officers for their
report and positive recommendation
for the reserve management application
which we fully support
valet homes are the country's fourth
largest house builder we are one of the
number one five-star house builders in
the country and the essex division
builds over 900 homes per year
belway acquired the site in 2019 in
december
following the grant of outline plan
commission and we have worked positively
with officers for nearly a year
through both the pre-application
discussions and the determination period
the proposals respond positively to the
parameters set by the outline planning
permission
for example we have respected the no
build zone to the northern section of
the site
we've enhanced the pedestrian routes
through the site we've created a
landscape buffer along the eastern
boundary with a 1.8 meter high fence and
extensive tree planting
and we've enhanced the woodland to the
south of the site to create safer paths
and dedicated wildlife areas
berway are committed to delivering this
scheme as soon as possible
with the social housing being provided
on as early as possible within the bill
process
ahead of the timing requirements and
triggers within the 106.
in summary your officers have concluded
that the proposals are acceptable in
planning terms
therefore respectfully request that the
application be approved in accordance
with the officer's
recommendations thank you
thank you very much i was just there
there's any questions for you from
members
uh i've got one there was a comment from
the parish council
that you have informed them that you do
not build
bungalows bear in mind that uh
most uh well certainly the parish
council
and i and perhaps other members were
under the impression the in indicative
um
plans that were put forward for um
outlying did show
more bungalows possibly 16 or 17
uh we're down to three what's what's
your answer to that
i mean it's certainly misleading
um we acquired aside from pigeon they
had obviously negotiated with with the
planning officers
and and the parish um when we met with
the
uh the council uh given the setbacks on
the eastern boundary
and the fact that the master plan wasn't
actually conditioned
as to be a an addictive master plan it's
just generally in accordance with um
so there wasn't anything set in stone
with the bungalow
it was felt that it wasn't something
that given the
the adjacent boundaries and the
distances between the houses it wasn't
something that was uh required for
immunity issues
um generally bilbo don't build bungalows
there's the occasion where we do
particularly for the social
we just feel that it's it's something
that that
the residents don't generally want we
can't it's very hard to sell them
and people want to build up um whenever
you get a bungalow they just want to go
into the roof and then they don't like
it when you take away that right to do
that through permitted development to be
excluded so
thank you very much so just to be clear
you acquired the site from pigeon
it wasn't your your outline
thank you thank you right members i've
got some hands up i've got councillor
hinton followed by councillor erwin and
followed by
councillor osborne we'll take councillor
hinton
thank you mr chairman just a quick
question on the
western boundary uh during the officers
presentation we heard that there was
some negotiation
with the county councillors to a a
barrier stroke fencing along the
line of the 137 um to prevent access
through there
bearing in mind that at the last meeting
we gave permission for
a fast food outlet at the top of bourne
hill there which obviously
might provide a an attraction to the
people on this
the development uh what are you
proposing to put along there that'll
stop people from
from accessing the 137
perhaps you could hand and moot
we cannot hear you sorry sorry
along the a137 um there is the poster
rail fence there's also
uh existing vegetation we'll be
improving that vegetation
and patching up the hedge any loss of
hedgerow that there is in there
um there is a big ditch that goes down
and then it comes back up again so
there's quite an extensive area
between the back of our site and the
a137 anyway
and the fact that we are dedicating a
path on the eastern boundary and
people can use that path now as opposed
to trying to cut through any kind of gap
in a hedgerow
um but we obviously we can't we can't
cut it off because it's a public
right of way so we're limited to what we
can do but we can discourage people from
using it by planting
and a post on our offense thank you
uh councillor osborne no sorry no
councillor owen
cancel on what's next thank you mr
chairman
um just a quick question um has the
apartment blocks got um
a shared outside space for them to hang
their wash in
and things like that
uh there will be some outside space yeah
i don't know about
washing lines and things like that but
yeah there is a mean displacement
surrounding
the block thank you
cancel osborne
clinton thanks thank you mr chairman
yeah um
just two two questions really that uh i
would like the agent to
respond to the commencement time limit
has a time being proposed for for the
start of this commencement of this
site uh we're literally gearing up at
the moment so
we obviously we've been waiting for
planning permission but we've we've got
all the working drawings done
it's literally a case of we will be on
site in september
thank you and the second one is um
the um landscape and management plan
now i i take it that any of the
any of the uh management of the site
in terms of open space and stuff will be
the responsibility of the
residents i might am i correct on that
and therefore there will be a
uh maintenance uh set up um
management's charged will have to be
paid for by
by contributions from the residents
correct
that's correct yeah there will be a
management company set up which we've
already set up actually
um and yeah all the residents will pay
into that and that will manage the
on-site
um landscaping on that northern section
what's to be determined is uh whether or
not they would also pay for um
the woodland honour or yet or whether
the council will take that or so on but
for the actual northern area yes there
will be a residence company
thank you thank you kenzler ayers
thank you chair um as you suggested
chair
um can i ask about the gravel um
footpath that would be
it's on slide um 32 um
because i it's very difficult to push
wheelchairs or
for push chairs um maybe that could be
reconsidered
and second question is would any of the
homes are being built
be homes for life thank you
um with regards to the uh the footpath
uh that is something that we're
discussing at the moment with chris fish
and highways
um and the uh public right away officer
um but there will be a a uh a plastic
membrane
that's got that the holes in it and then
the gravel goes into that all different
types of gravel and sizes so that it
won't wash away it's not just
compacted gravel it's within the um that
the plastic membrane so
it's got a lifespan of 20 30 years so
yeah that's the idea
uh building for lifetime homes i don't
believe that we are
um but i don't believe that's a
requirement at the moment anyway because
that's kind of fallen valve of building
regulations now so i think building
regulations sort have covered
lifetime homes anyway thank you
uh councillor busby
thank you um did you consider doing a
housing survey before you determine
what mix you're going to have for the
open market
uh no that's not something we generally
don't know it's just it's just gauging
from
previous experience in the area and
speaking to establishments and so on
well because every every housing survey
that we've done
or has been done in our area shows that
what is required is predominantly two
bedroom houses
and you've got no in fact over 90
percent of the
open market or three or four do you
think that's not
reflecting on the requirements of the
area
uh that was what we determined would be
to would be
needed at the time yeah right but if you
didn't do the housing survey how did you
know what it was needed
we've also got a site in um in hawley
uh that we've done a lot of market
research for that area as well
um and another site in which them that
we've done market research for that area
so it's a general suffolk
patch that um that we determined that
there is a need for two beds but
generally it's the larger houses that
people
are aspiring to uh particularly now
we've covered people we're finding that
people who want to move out
further away from from london whether
it's cheaper
and they can afford to do that in a
larger property and they don't need to
be running to train stations so
it has changed dramatically in the last
six months there's also an element of
people want to be able to work at home a
lot more so
we're finding that the house types are
changing slightly and that we're having
to provide
more sort of studies and so on or a
separate dining room so
they could work there thank you
good answer thinking on your feet
anymore yeah the you mentioned about the
public right of way
uh to stop people going on to the a137
sure it's not a public right of way you
could
you could fence off the uh of the
development from the road
no we can't it's a probably right of way
that that northern section
not along the eastern boundary that's
just within our site but
at the very very top um it does cross
over the a137 and that part
is the public right-of-way part um so
there isn't anything we can do to stop
people
across you know the a137 they've ever
won that because that is a probably
right way going across that road which
is
when you started you said the top do you
mean
the most southern part or the most
normal northern part
okay well as it sort of goes round into
the strand
yeah um that then
there is a right right into the strand
it goes left across
into uh effectively across the road
um and that area there we can't cut that
off
want to cancel
thank you chair can you hear me yeah yes
yes
um sarah i'm interested in the
design of the flats um
that's a very limited amount of
bungalows
what um are they going these flats going
to offer for people with a disability
recognizing that is an all-age thing
it's not just about older people
what emphasis on disability is going to
be
and what facilities in this block of
plants
um well they're not for the general
public they're
they're for the affordable housing so
it's to me it's
it's the requirements within a 106 egg
so it has to meet the sizes
that's within the 106 for those flats
for the one and two by flats in there
um so it's whatever the hate the housing
association will need and
they've been designed according to that
uh that's a one bed
two person or two bed four person and so
on um so it's to meet their requirements
and they've got very strict requirements
as to what they require right it's not
sort of general public
oh right i didn't realize that
disability was different for different
people but um
no but but the housing association will
have their own requirements to make sure
that
they're fit for purpose for for whatever
needs they need and will they
input then the design of the flats
uh well yes to a certain element we will
what's been approved will be built but
there are tweaks you have to have
we'll have an agreement with that the ha
provider and if they want certain
elements then that will be negotiated
through the the more design process
as it gets passed off to them and
they're
get signed off and given over to them
yeah okay
thank you very much chairman thank you
we have cancelled jameson
sir thank you chair um could you
tell me what environmental
sustainability measures you're
planning to put in place
um there's uh within the
northern section of the site there's
extensive tree planting
um there's new hedgerows to create
um new wildlife within there there's
hedgehog
holes within the um
the fences there's pollinator grassland
to encourage all the bees
um there's obviously all the planting on
the northern section
and then within the southern parcel
which is the woodland
um we're still liaising with
um place services with regards to that
but there will be
extensive areas that would be closed off
for
um ecological monitoring and
enhancements of ecological areas
through the us that you can't the past
won't be going through this for people
to disturb them
yes relates to the biodiversity but what
about the properties themselves
in terms of pv
there is there isn't that there's
obviously um there is a condition i
think it's condition 30 that we might
have signed off
already that's to do with the um
sustainability of the building but
that's just
mainly through kind of building
regulations and so on that we need to
encourage the kind of the
solar um uh
retention and so on within the buildings
but but there's no pv panels now
um um what sort of
this just general uh building rigs then
basically yeah
yeah okay thank you
uh councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman yeah just uh one
question that i failed to um
i forgot to ask the um affordable
housing
and um the materials that are going to
be used
i'm can i have the assurance that they
will not look any different to the
houses that they are going to construct
when the materials
are actually approved so in other words
um they will not look uh
different to to the rest of the site
please no the the materials are used
throughout we haven't um
we haven't allocated a certain area
within the social that gets different
it's just throughout just a blanket
across with with the um
with the bricks and the roof tiles is
just a blanket of course so they
shouldn't look any different they're
just
yeah that's the idea thank you
councillor plum
thank you chair um just a very quick
question
if we were minded to approve this but
insisted that the affordable housing is
pepper potted through the site
what would your reaction be um
my reaction is that we've spent the last
year
negotiating with the planning officers
the the layout of this
game it's taken a lot of time to to get
to the point we're at
if we start changing where the location
the affordable is
if you look at the houses it's very hard
to just try and pick some up
and put them somewhere else um it's
it's going to be a whole new replan of
the whole scheme which is going to take
even longer to get through
even more money even more time scales
it's going to be
you know starting from scratch again
effectively and redesigning it all
um there may be an element of we can
pick a few units up and put them
somewhere else but
we're talking about one or two really um
nothing generally that's there's going
to be
otherwise it's going to be a whole scale
redesign of the layout
thank you thank you councillor barrett
thank you um just wondered um if
all the properties will be able to put
their bins behind their properties by
side gates and so on
yeah that's good thank you
thank you um
i don't think there's any others hands
up
so i'm assuming that everyone's asked
the questions that wanted to
so thank you very much um
to to you we'll then move on i'll now
ask the ward member to speak councillor
gold are you with us
gold sorry chair we have not had any
reply from councilor gould we have left
messages but we haven't had a reply
okay then members will have to move on
um do do you want to take a
uh five minute comfort break just to see
whether we do get her
and um that yes i'm seeing some nods
members we'll we'll meet back at 20
to 11 so we've got about seven minutes
um a comfort break
and that will just give the opportunity
to see if we can get cancer gold
and if she's not there when we come back
then we'll carry on without her
okay thank you so please don't discuss
this
in the meantime thank you
welcome back members um i think uh we're
all present but i'm going to ask for a
roll call
you'll get an update on the um
board member and um councillor busby
wants to put a question
to the agent which i will just go back
and delay that question to be asked
okay um first of all can you do the roll
call
please thank you chair
councillor suez present councillor peter
beer
present councillor dave busby
councillor john hinton president
councillor lee jameson
president counselor mary mclaren
councillor mclaren are you with us or on
mute sorry
i was having difficulty okay no problem
thank you
councillor adrian osborne president
councillor allison owen prison
councillor stephen plum president and
kenzler barrett
councillor melanie barrett i do
apologize i'm here
thank you um we have had apologies sent
now from councillor gould she will not
be joining us chair
thank you right members i have had a
request from
councillor busby he wishes to put a
question that he wanted to put to the
agent uh she's agreed to answer it so
councillor busby would you like to put
your question before we move on
well actually it's a question kind of
two parts really the first one is
does uh the applicant or the agents uh
ask for or have a copy of our latest
consultation document on the local plan
uh i don't have a copy i would gain
access to it via your online website so
you you would
have read the relevant policies and mark
are you still there because the question
to you is
would we send a copy of the relevant
policies uh
no not as a matter of rope we wouldn't
know i mean
unless he's on our list of consultees
for such a document then no
so we don't send each applicant a copy
of
the the current policies what no no we
don't
know i just don't expect them to have
made that in
investigation themselves okay
okay thank you very much we'll now move
on uh so as counselor gold is not
present
um we're now into debate so
um again i'd ask you to put your hands
up if you wish to speak
but i'll start them even by going to
councillor ayers first to see if she's
wants to take part in the debate
councillor ayers
not at the moment thank you chairman
thank you um
anybody else there's no hands up who'd
like to start
somebody's hand is raised uh
um canceling mclaren
pencil and mclaren your hand is up
and you're muted
right sorry sorry the
joys of technology yes um
i certainly are a member of the planning
committee i would like
some explanation from either
ian or mark regarding this
uh statement by belleway that they
bought
the land from pigeon and pidgeon
had achieved the enlightened planning
permission
can somebody explain why the requirement
of the outline planning permission was
not transferred to bellway
desmond or mark i think it might be mark
uh thank thanks chair um i think
actually somebody might be sharing their
screen so i'm gonna get a double display
here but
anyway i'll carry on um the the question
is
was well what is the question sorry i
mean obviously there's an outline
planning permission
um and it and its obligations will then
pass the inheritor in title which in
this case is beltway
that's what happened that is what
happened so i don't understand what the
question is sorry counselor could you
yeah no sorry it was just that um
sarah said they they purchased from
pidgeon
but we'd have this discussion at the
outset about the number of bungalows and
how it had been changed
and i just didn't understand
i i thought perhaps there would be just
an automatic transfer
oh that there is yes understood yeah i
think this this turns on a debate about
what condition four meant and this may
come out in the debate but
but my advice is that that committee
having looked at the minutes
and the contents of it i can understand
why there was an understanding
that it would be that many bungalows but
actually legally and obviously this is a
kazi
judicial uh committee we're
we're undertaking here and if this went
to an appeal or an inquiry we have to be
clear on this
legally that decision notices did not
tie us down to the bungalows in my
opinion
it spoke of the layout which we are more
or less complying with this with these
latest drawings
but the matter of scale was a reserved
matter okay so i think there's a
mismatch between what was understood and
what was actually decided at the time
okay so can i just interrupt
so the lesson to learn from that perhaps
from what you're saying
is that if we feel that we um
that we believe there's x amount of
dwellings of a particular description
at outline we should somehow have that
written
into the outline that we're expecting 16
or 17
or three bungalows
yes chair i think the the conditions
have to be explicit
would have to be explicit and the reason
is because there is a condition saying
that scale shall be agreed and that's
what
that's what undermines the issue of the
bungalows i think so we've got to bear a
little responsibility for that but i
think it's a lesson learned
and that's a warning to applicants i
think in the future
uh ian you wanted to yeah yeah i'll just
come in briefly and say mark is quite
right i agree with him legally that's
all i need to say
yeah yeah we have to be legal we may not
like it but we have to be legal
thank you chair thank you uh i've now
got
uh
mclaren i believe you're sharing your
screen
would you be able to switch that off now
thank you right and could um
sarah carl uh could you turn your camera
off please
uh you can still hear us um but we can
still see you at the moment
that might help clear the that's that's
better
right uh i've now got and you can still
hear us sarah
yes
okay can the agent still hear us
yes yes i can hear you oh good thank you
uh councillor hinton
sorry about that mr chairman i'll just
uh checking up on some some policies
because of course with
what we're dealing with here is worsted
which is a village
uh and you'd expect things like cs11 to
apply but in actual fact it comes under
the general
the the general policy of the ipswich
fringe
um but this isn't an allocated site
within the
ipswich fringe um
the only only sites that are allocated
on the existing plans are
for employment use
but um the point i i wanted to
wanted to make on this particularly
is that one that we've got no housing
need the the applicant has admitted that
they they haven't got a housing
needs they don't do a housing need they
base it
on their experience at other locations
across suffolk
hall is quite a long way away from us um
and as the county council
and all the councils in suffolk have
signed up to a so-called climate
emergency perhaps we ought to be asking
our
cabinet member for the for uh
the environment to be uh looking at
these things and trying to decide uh
sorry about that the cameron really
followed
cancer hinton they've gone quiet and
frozen
kenzler hinton
councillor hinton can you hear us
uh i'll have to ask the officer to make
a phone call please
yes chair i will ask mandy to uh hit me
up to get her
just freeze from making any comments
members so just
wait for this to happen
peter peter somebody's sharing the
screen still
because i haven't got the full screen
yeah there the the blinking computer
fell off the table
we can hear you john uh i don't know
who's sharing the screen but i've i
believe chair that
counselor mclaren you're still sharing
your screen
right
i just made contact with council hints
and he says he's um
trying to he's joining as we speak
apparently so you will be joining us
shortly
back on mr chairman that's good sorry
about that
mclaren hold on clint kensington
you're sharing your desktop so if you go
to the um
control panel um to the left of the
three buttons there's one which says
share screen
oh i see that sorry if you click on that
and click it off
that's it that's great thank you i'm
sorry it's never happened before
sorry thank you so we've got there so
that's it
sorry john we're going to go back to you
uh
sorry about that no that's fine you
carry on there fell off
the computer fell off the desk or half
fell off the desk um
touch of the fat fingers i think bobby
is same as mary with her
shared screen button problem i don't
have a frozen picture of you but we can
hear you
well that's no that's why that's frozen
never mind
um i'm not that good looking so don't
worry about that uh
suffolk county council and all the
districts in in suffolk have declared a
climate emergency and yet here we have a
developer who's suggesting that uh
they're building houses on the basis
that anyone in suffolk can go to them
uh which means of course that uh we're
encouraging commuting
and move movement around the district
because they're not exactly going to
cycle down the a14 from hawley
uh so we've got a bit of a problem there
and uh within the design and the
environmental mediation
measures for this development they're
really just playing lip service to
building rigs
uh rather than than showing a way
forward in terms of
producing houses that are kinder on the
environment etcetera
and what else have we got here
i put here lack of adherence to the
existing local plan because
although as i said earlier this is part
of the ipswich fringe
it is a village uh and um
is not an allocated site within the
local plan so things like cs11 which
would cover the housing need would come
on to it
and they don't obviously have a copy of
the local plan i don't seem particularly
interested in having a copy of the local
plan which is interesting
and the other comment was about the
pathways which uh
suez uh mentioned uh they're talking
about a
perforated membrane with different types
of gravel on the top of it well that
doesn't make it any easier for a
wheelchair
or a push chair to be pushed through it
um
so there's another sort of almost
brushing off
of the uh the concerns of the committee
members
and finally i would just say that when
we're talking about the open space on
this site they're talking about setting
up a maintenance company
but a larger area of that uh open space
is right next door to the flats which
they're not quite sure whether they've
got any open space for them to put up
clotheslines etc with them
so there's going to be some sort of
requirement for those people to use that
area for something or other even if it's
only for
spreading their washing out on the line
sort of third world on the ground third
world style
so generally speaking there is not a lot
of thought being put forward by the
developer to these reserve matters to
try and make this
site workable uh of
use to the to the community uh and
attractive to the area
thank you um uh i'm gonna ask the
officer mark russell to comment on
what you've just heard what you've just
said sorry thank you so i just want to
address one of the points that
counseling
raised obviously raised many valid
points but just that the opening
sentence is about the principle of the
development just to remind members that
the permission exists um so we're there
are you know there's a permission for 75
dwellings there so
it's it's been allowed in principle
we're just now looking at the details i
just want to remind members of that
that's all
yes but uh councillor hinton does have
quite a few valid points
other points if i could just come back
on that
yeah councillor hinton
councillor hinton we seem to have lost
you again
come on get on with it sorry um
as i pointed out earlier on in the
meeting we seem to be shut out of the
conditions on this and a lot of the
conditions are what we're talking about
here
and they don't seem to be uh um
applicable to or suitable for the
development that we would like to see
here thank you
um any other comments members
um counselor busby
thank you what i thought we were here to
determine uh
the application complied with layout and
scale
is that not the case mark
thank you councillor busby um just
looking at the um
looking at the decision notes again for
that for the hybrid and i think that it
was
just for access yeah the hybrid one the
first one was for access
but we here today to confirm layout and
scale aren't we that's one of the things
that we're doing
yes we are yes we are yes yes sorry that
misunderstood correct yes
so layout and scale does cover
bungalows pathways yes
agreed or didn't agree with the first
one yeah
we can say we don't like the mix for
whatever reason
we don't like the layout for whatever
reason we don't like the fact that three
stories for whatever reason
you can consider all of those things i
was just merely suggesting that
that it couldn't be tied to the
understanding that there would be
bungalows you now have to look at what's
being
offered and what's good or bad about it
yes correct
yeah i agree although it's it's
it's a bit like ringing bmw up isn't it
and ordering your new car
and they're saying yes we'll we'll have
that ready for you in three weeks and
then when you go and get it it's a
vauxhall
it's not quite the same thing is it when
we've had
this application come to us and peter's
right the chairman's right we are going
to have to be tighter in what we
put in the minutes and get it and get
agreed because outline planning
permission
basically the way we're treating it at
the moment is just to cart blank
to do what they like and that can't be
right
um any other members well i have another
point as well
sorry go on then yeah i know we didn't
do a housing needs survey but on pace
um 26 of the emerging local plan
it says the demographic projections
identify there is an estimated to be a
total of 47
198 households that will be resident in
baber in 2036.
this is a thousand 203 more than the
previous
of the evidence september 2017. the
household type
breakdown is as follows one person 30.3
percent
coupled with no children 35.1
and then it goes on so effectively
by 2036 we expect 65 percent
of our population to be either single
or just a couple with no children why
are we building three and four bedroomed
houses
that's not what they want they want one
or two bedroom houses they cut
you know so the fact that the
i don't see that there is this need as
john says you know you saying
well yeah and hawley we sold all the
four bedroom houses
that's fine i mean
the redesigner the the
agent doesn't want to do a redesign
because of the cost i can understand
that
but to say that uh bungalows are not
needed
because they don't build them that's the
fourth largest builder in the country
you know if you can't build bungalows
which must be
easier than three story blocks of flats
um i just don't follow the logic behind
that
um and the reason
i guess that pigeon put 16 bungalows
or whatever it was alongside the eastern
boundary
the one that matched was alongside the
existing houses in bourne hill was
because of a concern
that was put forward to them between the
parish and the
uh the councillor that we didn't want
them
to be overlooked and the same applies
now
the same applies now thank you
um any other views
counselor barrett
thank you chad i i wonder if if we ever
knew
how many bedrooms were proposed for
these bungalows that were the
in the original plan and whether it was
ever
ever ever sort of detailed um because if
they were
they were going to be two bedded and now
they're replaced by
three bedded houses that is also quite a
material
difference um because it's it increases
the overall you know
number of people on that site quite a
bit and and built
um you know
size of uh of buildings an appearance
so appearances is altered layouts
altered scales altered
um it seems that the original
uh approval was for something quite
different
and i i think it might not have been
detailed
in a legal agreement but there was a
principle and an understanding um and i
think that probably should be
respected by the developer
i think i have to remind you that we
have to deal with what's in front of us
although i i
i'm of the view um that i understand
where
both you and councillor busby are coming
from um
chair i can answer the question about
the there were
the open market bungalows and there were
13 were all
two bed yes um but
i don't know whether any of that was in
detail in the outline uh
mark um mr russell detail on the
on the plan yeah um mark can you help
i think the easiest answer is to repeat
myself from earlier probably there may
have been a drawing showing that and
that that fed the understanding that the
council busby's now describing but again
we come back to the
it's the layout it's the same layout
i think it just really points out that
we must be sure at outline
in future uh that to get this really
clarified and sewn up
if that's the feeling that we want
certain types of dwellings
anyway um any new comments by members
no um well we need to
move forward um on this
so um members
well there's no proposal coming forward
so you leave me
in yeah may i just interrupt that i
believe councillor barrett was
attempting to speak then am i right i
apologize i thought it looked like you
were saying something
that leaves me in the position that um
we need to move on so i'm going to have
to reluctantly and i'm going to say the
words reluctantly
move the officer's recommendation
um so do i have a secondary
no that's fine so now i have to put it
back to you members
there's no seconder so um
i i do need one of you to come forward
i'll come forward in a second so we can
have the debate i mean
i'm not convinced that we have enough
reason to turn it down i'd like to
because it's not what i right well i
wonder let me just ask the load through
legal
and mark can we defer this so that we
can
have a discussion with the applicant
further
or do you think that is impossible
after you go first mark i i think that's
an option that we should explore
um chair if if members aren't minded to
go with the officer's recommendation
today
i i'd like to unpick exactly which
elements we're looking at yeah we've got
a little bit into the market housing
side i'm not sure whether we want to go
too far down that line
um but you've possibly referred to
um the location of the of the affordable
that's come up in conversation whether
that should be looked at i don't i don't
know which elements you would like to be
perhaps clarified i i think the elements
and we can discuss this in a moment
is the bungalows it's the affordable is
the
um footpath system um
and i think there was a concern with
park and the council of barrow
um comment on very early so they they
may be
they may be areas you want to um look at
members
um ian is there anything you want to
advise us before i go through them
mark has put it very well from they say
so i don't need to add anything at this
stage unless you've got the members have
any questions for me
yeah now if we go for a deferment so
that the
officers can have a discussion with the
applicant
members what do you want to put forward
for discussion review um
consideration councillor
um i'll start with you busby sorry i'll
start with you
well i think the main thing i know mark
said about the
uh open market but it is by far the
largest proportion
of the housing that's going to be built
there and as i mentioned
90 percent that are over three or four
bedroom houses is
isn't the doesn't reflect the mix that
we need
um and i think quite frankly
if we could go back to that uh
original layout where the two-bedroom
bungalows are alongside the eastern
boundary
i think that would make it a much better
development i think there does need to
be some space around the
affordable flats so that they can do
things like drying clothes at the moment
it doesn't look like there's anywhere to
do that kind of thing
and it seems that it's the devil's in
the detail with these things
i know it's only a small issue but if
you've got to live with it all the time
if we haven't catered for these kind of
things then the place looks like a tip
and they get a bad reputation and it's
built down to poor design
not their living standards right so
it's no small things i think no so i've
got mix
i've got flats outside space uh i've got
councillor plum that's got his hand up
so i'll go to you next
thank you chair um i'll go back to the
point of
trying to pepper pop the affordable
right yeah good
affordable
pepper pot yeah
right uh i've got canceler ayers
thank you mr chairman again it's that
pathway if you look at slide
32 um it's quite a long pathway and i do
feel
um for push chairs wheelchairs
bicycles whatever really that needs to
be considered
i don't think it's suitable all right i
paid a note of that as well
um i've got kenzler hinton
thank you mr thank you mr chairman yes i
was going to mention the
surface treatment of pathways yes which
sue's already brought up but also i
think that that boundary treatment to
the 137
uh all the way along its length of of
the site
up to where it joins up to the um ski
slope
complex etcetera needs looking at as
well because as i said earlier we
put a given permission for a fast food
outlet at the top of that hill
and people are not going to walk all the
way around the outside of the site down
to the bottom of the hill and then all
the way up the
up the side of the hill to get to it
they're going to cut across the road and
if we're not careful we're going to see
people and burgers splattered all over
the place
all right um the kenzler jameson
all right yeah just can we also get some
more get the
applicant to put in some more specifics
on environmental measures they're gonna
they can have on their properties
um environment
yeah yeah rather than just the
biodiversity actually what they're gonna
do
with the properties themselves yeah it
seemed very basic
what they were suggesting yeah well yeah
but they seem to skirt the um
topics so yeah that would be good yeah
right thank you
um council hinton your hands up did you
want to come back
yes just basically on the on that uh
environmental issue of course
uh whether it be on uh water catchment
within the within the site for
uh recycling water for uh brown water
brown water use um
but all right these aren't close to a
flood area and we know that a lot of the
properties along the bottom of
worsted strand there get flooded so
there's
often too much water about but it's the
wrong sort of water
and drinking water supply across suffolk
and particularly east suffolk is getting
to be quite a scarce commodity with all
the development we're doing
water pressures are steadily falling off
and anything we can do to sort of
encourage developers to put in water
conservation
systems the better thank you
yes you have great knowledge on the
water situation so that's very
helpful um there's no other hands up
i've got doing one two three four five
six
um pins and i'll just read them out in
case um
uh the mix and we are also referring to
the um occupancy of those um
dwellings that are proposed and we are
concerned
of the lack of bungalows i think can be
picked up in that
flats outside space particularly for um
drying of clothes and what have you
the affordables are not pepper potted
not all together they should be moved
all throughout the site
the environment um and water recycling
that was another point and the pathway
surface treatment and um the other
aspect that
councillor hinton referred to going over
the main road
uh those are bits i've picked up mark um
hopefully you've been writing these down
can you put them into some sort of
sensibility for us please
yeah i i can care with that list i'll
just go through them i want to revisit
the first one in a minute but just
the list was the bungalow sorry was the
mix including a bungalow consideration
yeah space around the flats um to pepper
pot the affordable
pathways because of wheelchairs etcetera
boundary treatments to the r137
environmental measures which included
solar panels and grey water
now the first one on the mix um i've
i've
shared my opinion on the on the bungalow
part of that i don't know what the
committee's aspirations are for for this
mix um
there was a suggestion by council busby
there were too many four betters for
example it's all towards the
larger number of bedrooms rather than um
i think we're gonna have to go away and
consider
the policy position on that and and and
uh
well we're gonna come back at some point
um we're gonna have to consider what the
policy position is on
insisting on smaller dwellings i mean
that there is there is a housing needs
survey there there is some scope to look
at this and to
and to answer councillor busby's concern
i can't promise we'll come back with
everything you want but
on the bungalows um at the moment in the
new
emerging local plan um
we've um said three percent
that we're looking at
yeah because we haven't got any at the
moment
and so three percent they've gone
playing it safe
uh the the this application actually
offers four percent in fairness to them
um but i think i i think they need to do
a pr
relationship the general feeling of the
parish council the general feeling
of members um was that there was going
to be more than
three bungalows and i think that's
that's the point we want to get over
um 16 and 17 would be wonderful but
i do understand and i think members will
have to understand that but
certainly three looks like they're
taking the mickey
all right well well we we've we've heard
the points you you've raised chair
if the committee agrees we'll come back
at a subsequent committee which probably
given the amount there is going to be
later than we thought
right so
the point about the mix it's it's the
disparity between the local plan say it
looks like
65 percent of our population require two
bedrooms or less
and the open market delivery is nine
percent
okay that's the gap that we need to to
narrow by having more two-bedroom
houses or bungalows preferably bungalows
and i think the three percent that is a
figure that needs to be argued over for
our local plan i'm not certain that just
refers to
affordable housing or whether it's
across the board
so i i think we need to be careful about
pitching too much
importance on that three percent all
right uh we'll check the policy position
for you and
what's up today in the spd and
everything like that counselor and um
and we'll consider that right uh before
uh uh so i'm gonna need a proposal and a
second at the moment
if i may please interrupt sorry it's
easily adviser
i think i'm looking to mrs philpot for
agreement on this declare i think
we did have a proposal and a second and
and a seconder for
uh the officer's um recommendations he
didn't get affected us
but i think oh well i mean i think he
did yeah we did
so i think really i think he needs um
you or councillor busby to officially
change your mind and say
you no longer want to do that um sorry i
did not get a seconder to my proposal
so we could open the debate ah sorry i
didn't hear that
right but i'm happy to change my mind
and that's fine
councillor busby is withdrawing his his
uh
his wishes that's fine
there is no so the the the the
chairman's proposal that we approve in
accordance with the
with the officer's recommendation is
falls for lack of a second er
correct i'm just checking mrs philpot
are you happy with that
yes thank you right okay so we now we
can now have a further
difference so now i must ask someone to
propose what you've
heard said by mark and i'll get him to
read it out
and then would somebody like to propose
that mark will you read it out again
please yes we've suggested to you
there are six points uh the top one was
uh to revisit the mix including looking
at bungalows
second was to look at space around the
flats the third
third was to um look at pepper potting
the affordable
fourth was pathways um for use of
wheelchairs etc
uh are you not gravel um fifth was
boundary treatments the a137
and finally environmental measures
including things such as solar panels
and grey water
thank you um so your
your somebody is proposing a deferment
for the officers to look into those
with discussions with the applicant
councillor busby
i'm prepared to propose that chair thank
you do i have a secondary i'm prepared
to second it mr chairman
thank you councillor hinton's second
that is there any
um comments or debate on that
no uh councillor barrett
may i just say about the pathways
surely there's a a standard uh
of a pathway that is suitable for uh
wheelchair use
and a buggy use and so on that we can
adhere to
without it having to be tarmacked
because if you tarmac it then it becomes
very urban looking and if it's going
through the green area you want to
try and retain that sort of element it's
a bit more rustic
so isn't there some some some pathway
that can
achieve both sure there is bark
uh the thing that that sprung to mind
was something like a bonded gravel
so it would visually look the same but
wouldn't move about and would be easier
to
wheel wheelchairs over et cetera that
was my thought
so there is room for some movement there
so that would be taken aboard
now oh i've seen some of those quite a
few hands gone up now
canceller osborne yes
uh thank you mr chairman yeah um on on
melanie's um
uh position on on the foot pass surely
the permeable surface has got to be
looked at on this because of uh
flood risks etc and water um
problems so you know you need a
permeable surface not tarmac
thank you thank you uh counselor ayers
thank you chair um i would suggest that
we contact the
um the special woodland that we have
behind the key theater
because they have pathways there that
are suitable for push chairs wheelchairs
whatever um so i can contact them if
need be
thank you thank you i'm sure if you pass
that information on to
the officer russell um that would be
most helpful
um right there's no other hands gone up
then i've had a proposal to defer
the application for more discussions
with the applicant
for the following reasons that's already
been set out proposed by
councillor busby seconded by councillor
hinton
i will now ask for a roll call um can
you take us through that clare
thank you chair when i call your names
if you could um
answer four against or abstain
councillor sue ayers
four councillor melanie barrett
four councillor peter beer four
councillor dave busby four
councillor john hinton paul councillor
lee jameson
for councillor mary mclaren for
councillor adrian osborne four
councillor alison owen four
and councillor stephen plum four why be
different
thank you nice unanimous chair yes i
agree unanimous
thank you very much that is the
situation
uh sorry chair for the record i didn't
catch who was the uh seconder for that
one
uh councillor hit john hinton john thank
you
and it wasn't because i twisted
councillor plum's arm either
all right thank you thank you uh
right so we've had that um so we've got
to the end
of the plan and meet and members uh this
will come back to us in due course
um i'd like to thank you for in minutes
chair
oh yes that's right thank you well done
uh can we go back to the second part let
me get the paperwork
uh minutes of the meeting held
on july the 29th have you had chance to
ever look at it hopefully you did in
that break
yeah yeah um can i have a proposal that
we accept the minutes
i propose chair that's canceller ayers
do i have a secondary
second i'll second it
right any comments
no all those in favor we accept oh no we
go over roll call sorry
um can you do the phone call again um
yes thank you chair councillor suez
um yes councillor melanie barrett
four councillor peter beer for
councillor dave busby paul
councillor john hinton councillor lee
jameson
for councillor mary mclaren
councillor adrian osborne councillor
allison owen
councillor stephen plum for again
thank you chair that's unanimous is that
correct can i have it confirmed
yes that's unanimous chair yeah
unanimous chair
thank you it's been confirmed right
members
thank you very much for your attendance
and enjoy the rest of your day